they're buying drinks for everybody as
soon as she comes over I mean who does
that you can come back to the bar you're
literally
how is that possible I can't be an
[__] I got arms and legs and a head
all right everybody focus on look this
party tonight could be a model for the
way that the world should work
and I just want to say
I'm totally stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good oh yeah
Dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
I might run for office someday
now trust me I think that this party can
be the most inspirational party this
campus has ever seen is that coming to
me and just grab that
[Music]
some racial Spud some righteous fun we
got going on there we need some
Bodacious jock babes coming in yeah we
need some hot ass punk rock babes I I
don't care where they come from the most
important thing it's imperative that we
have a diversity in the uh [__]
Department intercepted I don't sleep on
burial
uh don't ever sleep on burial
[Music]
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
that is that there we go come here get
this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody weed
all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this this
is I'm really Frosty right now by the
way this is your Constitution all right
it's just a piece of paper we got to
keep its Integrity because it's going to
hold everything together this right here
this is us this is the American people
we're special we're magic hello yay we
all live in here all right the most
important thing is that we don't get too
far apart me and you we got to be close
that's that's the magic of America's
love otherwise we're gonna get air
bubbles in there it's gonna start
canoeing and everything we don't want
that all right you get that all right
look
my way ahead of you but I'm already done
boom fireworks Fourth of July that's for
you we want like 10 of these
[Music]
what was I saying
all I know is it's good having another
brother move into the neighborhood hey
man it's good to have you over and I
think that you will dig this
hey nice guitar collection oh thanks
Manny you want to hear something
yeah sure all right all right
[Music]
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red white and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue
country music yeah I grew up in Texas
you know so all right keep her safe from
the homies in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking the reefer and
acting like
clown
dirty and brown cause that's the
American way
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
of black people black people but I'm
black
well keeping the red-headed girl away
from the homies on the wrong side of
town homies come on brother this is all
kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian homies
no homies are black no I think you're
making them black man I mean I think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark I like is when I turn off
the lights the only Hood I love is Pony
and white tan trust you if I can't see
your face at night I think we all know
wait wait hey stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only Hood I love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the clan man
the Ku Klux Klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know I can't just say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like um Farrakhan on me right now oh my
God are you serious dude hey give me you
know can I do one more let me just do
one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
[Applause]
okay
come on man hey
she's over here trying to sing about a
tire swing
light up an entire genre music
[Music]
oh damn now I see it
now I see it all right listen up y'all
I'm y'all substitute teacher Mr Garvey
I taught school for 20 years in the
Inner City
so don't even think about messing with
me y'all feel me
okay let's take a roll here
Jay quellin
where's Jay quellinet
no Jay quella here
yeah
uh do you mean Jacqueline okay so that's
how it's gonna be
y'all want to play
okay then
I've got my eye on you Jake pauler
Malaki
where is balakay at
nobelaka here today
yes sir my name is Blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
Blake what do you want to go to war but
lucky no because we could go to war no
I'm for real
so you better check yourself
be nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all says some silly ass name
this whole class is going to fill my
wrath now D nice
do you mean Denise
you say your name right right now Denise
say right Denise correctly Denise right
Denise right
be nice that's better thank you now
a a Ron
where are you
where is a a Ron right now
no AA Ron huh
well you better be sick dead or mute a a
Ron here oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
I said it huh huh I'm just you know I'm
just asking you know I said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time I said a a Ron
ounced Aaron
you're done messed up Aaron now take
your ass on down to osak Hennessey's
office right now and tell him exactly
what you did
who oh Shack Hennessy
principal O'Shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before I break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and churlish
Timothy
present
hey what's up Ted in the net come on in
yes all right thanks for coming
have a bloody good time awesome oh oh
here he is what's up Noah Michael
Jackson
hey
[Music]
ow nice oh some oh there we go
there we go
all right
four all right well Annie are you okay
oh he's leaning he's leaning are you
okay all right are you okay Andy are you
okay Annie you've been touched by a
smooth criminal oh
more kicks
close to your face
no more you want to come inside
that's annoying that is very annoying
stop stop don't do it anymore
just keep doing the Shimon that's where
the children
that's some bad taste
this isn't don't even know what that is
really eyes
what are you doing jamming Island no you
cut off I should both oh okay he doesn't
slap his ass like that so I don't know
what okay
hey
look
can we just
hey stop stop it stop it stop it
costumes awful the impression is stupid
and played out everybody and their
mother was Michael Jackson three years
ago when he died
you died
oh
wait wait wait he died oh Noah
oh no
what no wait wait a second don't sad and
walk away
happy Halloween
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party to the party
don't stop and the party don't stop
because it keeps on going non-stop gonna
party all night gonna keep this party
going cause the party won't stop it's
been two straight days and the party
still going two three four five six
seven days
all my friends drinks in the back we're
going to a party sending texts cell
phone rings iPad Facebook Party Time
skin tight jeans Friday nights dance
dance dance cause tonight we're going
out and we ain't coming back cause the
party won't stop it we'll go all night
Friday night every night
[Music]
foreign
city city
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
Party Don't Stop what universe is the
Family Circus better than Dilbert for
instance oh yo what's up man how you
then oh you know cuz
keeping it straight
no all right cool well I guess I'll
check you later all right dog
you should see it's raining people with
James Khan
and Shirley Knight that's uh
uh what's up man
yeah man um
how's Denise oh yeah Denise
anyway
I guess I'll catch you on the flip yeah
don't yeah ain't no time
no I'm in the dog I'm in there [__] it
I'm in there tuck it I'm talking Indian
boy I'm in there don't come in the door
nope all right
oh
[Music]
anyway you know you gotta come real come
correct when you come in at all you know
that's usually how I roll
are you
yeah well why don't you give it to your
new fat ugly girlfriend wait I didn't
even remember yet whatever you left your
jacket Megan started in a river why
would I do that I can't remember it fine
God
[Applause]
me again
they're buying drinks for everybody as
soon as she comes over I mean who does
that you can come back to the bar you're
literally
how is that possible I can't be an
[__] I got arms and legs and a head
where's my jacket I have your jacket do
you want it no you know what get eat it
why would I do that you know what I'm
not following you anymore
Megan come back to the bar yeah
pretty good
Negan do you want your jacket no
seriously come back to the bar you got
after the buyer I'm gonna throw this
jacket in the water oh nice that's
really nice what do you want me to do me
again damn kiss my butthole okay good
fine fine then I'm going I'm leaving
right now
God damn it
no like seriously your jacket yeah but
it's your jacket though
[Music]
Megan
I have your I have your jacket
[Music]
seriously me